for this project you will need the
printed copy of the template scissors
and tape cut out the five strips on the
dotted line
make sure to separate the co-joined
strips the green orange and yellow tabs
have to remain attached to their
respective strips proteins are polymer
chains of amino acid residues each
number on the model represents one amino
acid residue insulin has two chains tina
is green chain v is blue tape together
the two pieces of the a chain green so
that residue lemon is back to back in
the two pieces tape together the three
blue pieces of the B chain by
overlapping the gray tabs at the ends so
that all the numbers are visible on one
side and all the numbers are in order
some sections of amino acid chains curl
and formed alpha helixes due to hydrogen
bonds between NH and co groups the helix
regions on the model are marked on the
chains with darker shades of green and
blue start with residues 1 and 5 and
form of hydrogen bond between co and NH
and taped together keep creating the
hydrogen bonds until you reach the end
of the darker colored area when you
reach residue 6 make sure the green cap
is on the outside of the helix create
another alpha helix starting with
residues 17 and 21 keep creating
hydrogen bonds until you reach the end
of the darker colored area
starting with residues 7 and 11 form a
hydrogen bond keep creating the Alpha
helix until you reach the end of the
darker colored area
some amino acids give a turn to the
chain the turns are marked on chain B of
the paper model with the white dashed
lines fold outwards on the white dashed
lines to create the turn you can secure
the fold with tape
also note that chain B offs includes a
beta strand marked with a blue arrow the
structure of insulin is stabilized by
three disulfide bridges a disulfide
bridge --it is formed when a sulfur atom
from the residue cysteine forms a single
covalent bond with a sulfur atom from a
second cysteine the first disulfide
bridge connects two cysteines in a chain
a to form the bridge connect the green
tabs connect the yellow tabs matching
their shape while making sure the
colored size are facing the same way
connect the orange tabs matching their
shape while making sure that colored
sides are facing the same way
congratulations if you have completed
all the steps and your project looks
like the one shown here then you now
have your own insulin model